in 2020 satya nadella walked away with a
solid 44.3 million dollars as
compensation for being the ceo of
microsoft this makes satya one of the
highest paid non-founder executives in
the world only beat now by the likes of
sunder piche and tim cook satya did not
join microsoft with high level
connections like steve ballmer nor did
he join particularly early as he didn't
join until 1992 or 16 years after
microsoft was founded so here's how
satya nadella slowly worked up the
corporate ladder and became the ceo of
microsoft
satya was born on august 19 1967 in
hyderabad india his father was an indian
administrative service officer or an ias
officer and his mother was a sanskrit
lecturer satya would end up attending a
local public school called the hyderabad
public school and it seems like satya
was more or less an average kid
no biography about satya really points
out particularly interesting
characteristics about him he wasn't
noted for having an insane memory nor
was it known for being an overachiever
in fact in an interview with david
rubenstein satya reveals that he never
had ambitions of becoming a top
executive he preferred to just go with
the flow and approach life one step at a
time satya recalls that he just wanted
to study economics and get a respectable
job at a local bank meanwhile his
parents just wanted satya to stop
playing cricket and start taking his
education more seriously it was actually
satya's father that pushed satya to
major in engineering at the manipal
institute of technology which ironically
has the initials mit satya graduated
with a bachelor's in electrical
engineering in 1988 and after that
satya's father would push out yet to get
an education in the u.s
so satya started applying to master's
programs in the u.s satya would be
accepted into the computer science
department at the university of
wisconsin-milwaukee
he would graduate with his masters in
computer science two years later in 1990
and he would subsequently land a job at
sun microsystems it's unclear what
exactly satya did at some microsystems
but we do know that he worked on the i.t
side he didn't stick around for long
though as he would jump ship to
microsoft in 1992. at microsoft satya
worked on the windows nt operating
system and the interactive tv system
that same year satya married a girl
named anupama who was the daughter of
one of his father's friends a couple of
years later satya pursued an mba from
the university of chicago while working
full-time at microsoft satya would
secure the nba in 1997 and this helped
him move up the ranks within microsoft
at the turn of the millennium microsoft
underwent a massive corporate
restructuring as bill gates retired from
his position as ceo
steve ballmer would become the new ceo
and everyone underneath him got the
chance to move up this allowed satya to
score his first executive position at
microsoft as the vice president of
microsoft b central this division was a
rather unknown part of the company that
focused on providing professional web
services to small businesses nonetheless
this was a massive achievement for satya
given that he hadn't even worked at the
company for 10 years at this point his
personal life however wasn't progressing
nearly as smoothly in august of 1996
satya and anu had their first son named
zain satya describes that he was so
caught up in the little things before
zane's birth apparently he was trying to
figure out when anu could go back to
work and how they could enjoy their
weekends while taking care of their baby
and so on and so forth when zayn was
born though satya's entire life would be
turned around zayn had been suffering
from undetected ass fixation which
basically means that zayn wasn't getting
enough oxygen this resulted in severe
brain damage and eventually cerebral
palsy and quadriplegia for many years
after zane's birth satya struggled to
find answers
why did this happen to him and what did
he do wrong but over time satya came to
a realization with the help of his wife
while satya was understandably feeling
sorry for himself anu had completely
changed her outlook on life she gave up
her career and focused all her time and
effort on helping zayn live the best
life possible
this helped satya realized that nothing
happened to him
what happened happened to zayn and satya
had to understand and accept that
reality in order to be the best father
he could be
as you would guess this experience not
only altered satis approach to parenting
but also his approach to life as a whole
including his career
satya became more grounded empathetic
and modest than ever before as he
entered the new century in the early
2000s satya was promoted to corporate
vice president of microsoft business
solutions and just a couple of years
later in 2007 he would be promoted to
senior vice president of research and
development once again though satya's
personal life was lagging behind his
professional life satya's second
daughter was born with a severe learning
disability satya and anu were much more
prepared to help their daughter due to
their prior experience with zayn
but raising their daughter would still
prove quite difficult the closest school
that would best suit their daughter's
needs was across the canadian border in
vancouver which was about 2-3 hours away
from seattle so satya and anu decided to
split their family and live in different
cities to accommodate for their daughter
satya and zain lived in seattle while
anu and their two daughters moved to
vancouver the family would only meet on
the weekends
anyway satya continued to move up the
corporate ladder at microsoft becoming
the president of microsoft server and
tools business in 2011. satya's pivotal
promotion would come a couple of years
later when steve ballmer retired from
his position at seo
at the time satya was one of the
contenders for ceo but he wasn't the top
pick per se
during the interview process with the
board however satya quickly became the
top pick as we discussed throughout the
video satya never had a super big ego or
super ambitious dreams he was a pretty
modest guy and his experience as a
parent had just grounded him even
further
as a result when the board asked satya
if he wanted bc yoa satya replied only
if you want me to the board was visibly
confused by this response usually people
who wanted to be ceo knew it and they
were generally very confident in their
answers as to why they should be the new
ceo
satya's unique approach resonated with
the board and sathya would become the
ceo of microsoft on february 2nd 2014
since then i think satya has grown
microsoft using three core avenues with
the first one being embracing
competition for the longest time
microsoft placed great emphasis on being
as dominant as possible they went to
great lengths to ensure that this was
the case whether that be forcing
consumers to use internet explorer or
billing on apple to save themselves from
a monopoly lawsuit steve ballmer tried
to continue this approach steve pushed
microsoft into the smartphone market
despite it being quite clear that they
had missed the train
similarly steve oversaw the launch of
windows 8 that attempted to merge mobile
operating systems with windows which was
just a massive mess satya however was
able to come to terms with the fact that
microsoft had lost out on some sectors
and instead of pouring billions into
lost opportunities and trying to buy
themselves to the top satya conceded in
these markets and looked for ways to
collaborate with the winners instead of
trying to take them down
for example satya oversaw the release of
microsoft office on ipad and satya
launched microsoft apps like outlook on
android and ios satya even embraced the
use of the linux operating system on the
azure cloud
aside from working with the competition
satya reduced microsoft's focus on
windows and office
microsoft had already won the computer
operating system space and instead of
trying to milk consumers by launching a
new windows every few years satya
decided to take it easy satya oversaw
the launch of windows 10 which brought
back the familiar feelings of windows 7
and xp
he also made it pretty easy for
consumers to get windows 10 for free
while this may have not been the best
financial decision short term
windows 10 was essential in winning back
consumer trust at first there were even
rumors that windows 10 would be the last
major version of windows and that
microsoft would simply provide updates
every once in a while microsoft
obviously changed their mind given that
we have windows 11 now but the approach
has stayed the same microsoft did not
try to overhaul the windows experience
with windows 11. instead they opted to
keep everything pretty familiar while
making the experience more fluid and
reliable by taking it easy in terms of
windows satya was able to expand
microsoft into sectors that still had
opportunities left specifically cloud
computing and surface books azure is
credited as being satya's biggest
contribution to microsoft's business
while apple and google honed in under
control over the consumer cloud market
the enterprise cloud market was still
more or less dominated by aws which is
quite an expensive option satya cleverly
leveraged this gap in the market and
promoted azure as the cheaper
alternative to aws
once again satya did not try to take
over aws or outperform aws he opted to
capitalize on what aws wasn't doing as
opposed to what they were doing really
well
satya also picked up on the trend
towards lighter laptops pretty early on
google had come out with their
chromebooks which were quite attractive
to like users and students satya
leveraged this trend by launching the
surface book which has proven to be
extremely attractive to a niche group of
people
outside of these three fundamental
changes to microsoft satya also oversaw
a couple of major acquisitions in 2014
microsoft bought minecraft for 2.5
billion dollars in 2016 microsoft
acquired linkedin for 26.2 billion
dollars and in 2018 microsoft acquired
github for 7.5 billion dollars all of
these acquisitions have just further
propelled microsoft forward allowing
microsoft stock to explode 700 since
satya became ceo
so what can we learn from satya nadella
well more than his intelligence his
execution and his level mindedness i
think the biggest trade satya brought to
microsoft was character
satya brought humility
modesty and empathy to microsoft a
leader cannot change a company by
himself leaders need the support of
their employees and satya's character
was able to win over the employees of
microsoft more than basically any ceo in
the world
in fact satya ranks as the sixth most
approved ceo in the world according to
his employees with an approval rating of
97 percent to put that into perspective
tim cook ranks as 32 so their pitcher
ranks as 90 and elon musk doesn't even
make the top 100. considering this i
don't think any of you guys would be
surprised to hear that satya nadella was
promoted the chairman of the microsoft
board as well in june what do you guys
think about satya's modest rise comment
that down below
also drop a like if you think satya
success is more than well deserved and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions ultimately answered but until
then i'm hari i'll see you guys on the
next one